[Applaudissements]
taser l'estomac le vent ça m'a rien fait
moi même léger rhume mais c'est la porte
ouverte si vous raconte pas favori ça va
ouais foutu c'est chaque année pour son
anniversaire et j'y fais un cadeau
ah oui c'est vrai l'an dernier j'avais
offert le voyage organisé au sénégal ois
[ __ ] de [ __ ] sénégal bis sur ta pas
eu peur de se faire tirer dessus par
tous ces noirs toi tu rigoles ou quoi
çeku verger mutuelle humains assistance
aux femmes se fait tuer je prends 200
brick lace amène avec elle ça se gâte
briques
c'est pour ça on l'a mené on sait jamais
cette année j'ai offert la l'abonnement
à femme actuelle
[Applaudissements]
cette année cette nuit j'ai rêvé que je
vais te fais choper par un singe à son
peuple alors sa femme aux aidants quéré
de l'année j'ai ouvert le bal en femme
actuelle assez bien femme actuelle
est ce qu'il ya de bien avec ce magazine
c'est que chaque mois tu sais faut un
dossier passionnant
ah ouais et là il ya récemment ils ont
fait un dossier simple et j'ai 40 ans et
je veux jouir pas lui c'est clair je
veux jouer mais c'est pas possible
c est enfin voler ça mais c'est pas
possible c'est notre éthique mais de
continuer quand on regarde et fort
boyard la télé comme tous les femmes à
fort boyard c'est avec l'aîné qui coud
et j'aurais va se faire un show pc n'est
et le jour il veut se faire gauler vont
la voir la grosse aujourd'hui père
fouras c'est bon les naines cours et
nomma gm a fermé de but en blanc qui me
dit fernand j'ai 40 ans et je veux jouer
mais c'est pas possible pas ce cas ça
c'est pas possible
s'ils arrêtent synoptique ouais ouais
métier elle arrive ma femme voilà on a
parlé elle est là c'est pas ta forme ces
imbéciles mais tu vois ces deux jeunes
allemands vont risquer leur vie
alors donc j'ai dit que je ne devrais
pas me tue c'est en tout cas la serveuse
et bien gaulée way et donc elle elle se
retourne comme ça vers moi et me dit
j'ai 40 ans et je veux jouir
oui j'ai dû baisser c'est pas de
problème en quinze jours plus tard je
regardais moment
[Applaudissements]
merci joue la merci des jouets dragons
chevaliers du ciel
[Applaudissements]